hello hello hello everyone
welcome to what edition is this
week three of the book club
uh where we are reading the infinite
game
um welcome back welcome back we have
added twitter to our live feed now so we
are live on youtube linkedin facebook
and
twitter so hello uh the internet
universe uh as
always thank you everyone for joining us
from around the world
we've got brazil we've got dubai we've
got the uae
how are you uh nihon japan germany
um the wyan international book club
that's with you again the bridgehouse
book club in hamburg and
berlin good to see you um
lovely to see everybody from around the
world uh it's it's part of it's one of
my favorite things i
quite frankly if i'm honest i'm
completely blown away hello from india
um uh just hello from from sydney isn't
it the middle of the night there
it's like three o'clock four o'clock in
the morning there isn't it uh
exotic davenport florida liverpool um
scranton pa
um lovely to see everybody um thank you
for emailing all your questions and your
photos
it's so great to see them all um today
we're covering two chapters
chapter six and chapter seven uh will
and resources and
uh trusting teams um
uh and we'll be taking your question now
usually what i like to do at book club
is i like to talk about the chapter and
tell you some of the
behind the scenes stories and i'm going
to do a little differently i have
something really special so
in the the chapter of trusting teams you
may
recall um i uh
drew a chart a graph of trust versus
performance
performance versus trust um and i tell
the story of how i learned this
from the navy seals well i thought what
would be really fun to do is invite
uh the navy seal who actually taught it
to me
um he'll share some stories of how how
practical it is and take some of your
question
so without further ado uh retired
uh navy steel commander uh my friend
uh rich divini there he is good to see
you rich how are you
hey my friend how are you good to see
you i see quarantine is treating you
well
yes lazy my lazy beard your lazy beard
yeah uh
my lazy beard as well um although i
shaved it recently so it's it's a little
shorter than it was it got a little bit
out of control
looks good misty um uh thanks
thanks for coming it's always good to
see you um
we'll jump right in you know i remember
when you
uh when you and i were just i think we
were just at dinner when i first came
out to visit the navy seals
um and we were talking about what it
takes to perform
produce a high-performing team and you
drew this trust
versus performance matrix for me which
as you know has
has stuck with me i absolutely adore it
um
first of all how did you learn it yeah
so
so i was so when we when we when we
first met i was running training for a
pretty specialized seal command
but in that in the process of that i was
also
talking to and and conferring with the
the main steel command training
which is buds basic underwater
demolition so we were talking quite a
bit
and uh and the guy who was running that
at the time showed this to me this chart
he said hey this is kind of how i see
this thing we really
it really resonated with me and we kind
of took that and i took it back to what
i was doing
um because really what it told us was
that hey
you know trust and performance are
actually two different things
certainly competence matters certainly
however when it comes to assessment and
selection
uh performance typically uh looks at
skill
and i'll you know kind of go into the
differences here but skill there it's
very
really easy to measure and assess the
best the best shooter in the military
exactly best shooter best diet you know
scuba diver best skydiver in the
business example it could be the best
you know uh uh delegator or or
or critical thinking right yeah in
normal life it'd be riding a bike or
throwing a ball those are skills they're
very easy to see assess and measure
um trust comes from something different
something a little bit more innate
it's typically behavior and behaviors
come from what i call attributes and you
know
you and i've been talking for years
about my book coming out here in january
the difference between skills and
attributes but attributes are things
like patience situational awareness
empathy
humility uh when it comes to team
ability it comes to you know
conscientiousness integrity
those are the things we measure so
that's how it came to be and that's how
it worked
this is the question i get most often
you know which is you know
performance metrics are just very easy
to measure it's one of the reasons we we
have an unbalanced bias towards them
it's not because we necessarily believe
they're more important
it's just because it was easier so you
know one of the questions i guess is
is how do you measure patience how do
you measure
you know things that are more of our
character yes the attributes
uh show up so attributes are more
inherent to our nature okay we're pretty
much born with them
all of us have all the attributes it
just a bit depends on what level of
adaptability we have
um they are they they they inform our
behavior they show us how we're going to
show up to situation uh my
my patience my resiliency my
adaptability will show how i'm going to
learn how to
play qualitative it's all qualitative
it's qualitative but it's also
it's it's environment right uncertainty
challenge and stress
where where you can't apply unknown
skills skills direct behavior for a
known situation
uh uncertainty say that again slowly
that's good skills direct behavior for
known situations
skilled direct behavior for a known
situation right here's how to ride a
bike here's how to drive a car okay and
now the other part
when you get into an unknown uncertain
situations
right hills don't apply right we lean on
our attributes
okay this is what i love because this is
finite infinite games that's exactly
right because a finite player
likes to train and prepare so that
there's no such thing as unknown because
finite-minded players fear the unknown
they fear uncertainty
and so they practice practice practice
practice this is athletes this is
military
practice practice practice so that
you're prepared for any eventuality
and as as dr cars explained to me at the
time of something uncertain or unknown
the thinking has already been done the
thing kind of
yeah but the problem is the problem is
that works for expected things
that's exactly right that's exactly and
how many of us
throw the finite player into a tizzy
where the infinite-minded player
embraces uncertainty and as dr karst
explained to me where finite thinking
the thinking happened in the past it's
now
muscle memory right i didn't have to
think i just relied on my training you
hear it all the time
where the infinite minded thinker at the
time of uncertainty or the time
something goes
completely haywire now the thinking
begins and this is what you're saying
which is skills are good
for for finite mindedness but building
these attributes is really what it takes
to it to build an infinite mindset and a
trusted team when we talk about trusted
team we talk about high performing teams
okay high performing teams
aren't just good when things are going
great okay hyper
the truest high performing teams are
great when things go south and sideways
and i've seen it all the time
it was kind of what the idea for the
book was dream teams right i
get business people saying hey i just
built this dream team best sales people
top
graduates all these skills right
measurables but they're toxic the team's
toxic and when things went to
went to hell we all fell apart and i
said because you were looking at the
wrong things you need to look at
attributes you need to look at things
like
adaptability patience situation
awareness those things that we lean on
in uncertainty that's
that's what starts building the trust
because trust after all
are behaviors you know it's like you and
i are talking about trust is not
just a feeling you know trust is more
than just a feeling it's a belief a
feeling is just a human emotion
justified
all right no human emotion that's all it
is a belief is a human emotion justified
and rationalized
doesn't matter if it's right or wrong it
just matters that it has been so it's a
belief you can't make anybody trust you
all you can do is behave in a way that
allows them to make a decision to trust
you and that's what you're doing trusted
teams you're my
philosopher warrior friend um okay let's
take a couple questions
um i'm gonna i have one question from
brittany warship
um uh and i'm gonna let you field this
one
she says uh what is your advice for
building a trusting team
of teachers and administrators who can
navigate birth
so that they can navigate both uh the
uncertain and complex waters that lie
ahead this school year
okay great question thank you brittany
the um first first step is to understand
that trust
uh comes from behavior we we trust each
other because we behave in a way that
allows us to make that decision so
things like listening care empathy
those will immediately generate trust
when we talk about specific teams so in
this case teachers and administrators
are they how do they build a trusting
team yeah increasing the unknown future
yeah step one what are the attributes
we're looking for
okay so it's not just skill anymore what
are the attributes we're looking for
for this team because every team the
attributes that we need for a seal team
is different
are different from the attribute list
that we need for a team of teachers and
administrators what are those attributes
and then begin to assess
each other as to whether or not you have
those attributes this time of stress and
challenge
probably has assessed some of those
things we've already seen i'm sure
brittany you've already seen
who are the patients one patient ones
who are the adaptable ones who are the
ones with empathy
who are the ones with less empathy
things like that so
so understand the attributes you're
looking for and then
start to look and assess for those as
well
a a trusted team is a mesh of people
with skills and attributes that
complement each other and so
one thing trust requires is
vulnerability vulnerability does not
just mean
showing your weakness it means also
showing your strengths because i need to
know
if simon and i are working together i
need to know exactly what he's good at
when he's not good at he needs to know
what i'm good at
and what i'm not good at so i know when
to lean on him and he knows when to lean
on me what a trusted team
does so so look at that uh and
and start to think about that uh in
terms of your team
that's great um if anybody has any live
questions for rich
uh hello india hello pakistan hello new
zealand uh hello waterloo canada
um uh phoenix arizona if anybody has any
live questions for rich let's take one
yes
neil neil hall hi neil how can you
quickly understand
attributes through the interview process
how can you quickly
oh good one thank you neil uh how can
you quickly understand
attributes through the interview process
i guess it's good both ways interviewee
and interviewer
absolutely this is a great question i i
could go for hours
okay what i want to just say if you if
you're interested
uh go to the attributes.com uh we're
gonna post that in the chat room
you'll go to the landing page for the
book and you'll be you get to take an
assessment tool that we're building
to measure attributes we're we're
collecting data right now so if you if
you do this for us
we'll give you the free full assessment
so you can take it i know you're doing
it
yeah um so um how do you do it the the
here's the simple answer you throw
stress and uncertainty into the process
okay
if you want to find out so you can tell
someone hey i'm i'm um
i want to know how how good a presenter
you are presenting is a skill
okay so someone could prepare be they
they kicked butt on their
presentation that doesn't tell us much
well what if during the presentation you
throw in
a change right hey i'm sorry you know
two minutes we're just starting two
minutes you're not
you're not presenting on this anymore
you're presenting on this right right
see how they react this is exactly what
we did
in the seal teams it was fun our
environment admittedly in special
operations
it's this to a t i mean it's all
uncertainty that's why i i always
considered us we're kind of masters of
uncertainty because we trained in these
environments
yeah you can develop attributes
difficult
but you could because you can't sit down
and learn an attribute like you can a
skill
it has to be self-directed it has to be
a deliberate
process on yourself uh but throw stress
challenge and uncertainty at anybody
you're going to start to see
the attributes emerge so good uh you
know anything else you want to say
before you head off i know you have to
go
any any any stories from the teams um
to help us understand the value that
trust plays even amongst high performers
like
why trust was is is even more important
to you than just sheer
sheer grit and strength well let me
throw out a concept which we we cover in
the class that we that we're running
that simon
simon's team and i developed here so uh
but it's a concept that i realized when
i was running training there
at uh in the seals okay it's called
dynamic subordination okay dynamic
subordination takes the task
organization
organization model that we know whether
it's a pyramid the flat or the upside
down pyramid
and turns it into kind of what i'd say
is an amoeba or a blob
and the idea is where does the leader
sit in that blob
right right i would get answers center
right whatever
the answer is anywhere the leader needs
to be in a dynamic subordination
environment
that the team understands challenge and
stress and problems come from any angle
and whomever is uh capable of and ready
and closest to that problem steps up and
takes leads and everybody follows
right it's a dynamic swap between leader
and follower
quick example in the normal world okay
the captain of an airplane
on a commercial airline he is you know
by
he or she is in charge of that aircraft
right there's no debate
that person is in charge of that
aircraft however if when taxiing out to
take off the maintenance officer calls
and says hey
uh you got a problem you got to come
back to the gate no pilot
worth he or she her him or her wings her
his or hers wings
would ever say no i'm not turning back
they immediately defer to that expert
okay right that plane turns back that
plane starts to deplane well the pilot
doesn't take charge of de-planing either
he leans on the flight attendant right
that's the expert who steps up and takes
lead
that's dynamic subordination all right
so so even though he's fully in charge
the maintenance guy says you have to
come back and the pilot now becomes
subordinate
that's exactly right because there's
trust right you don't do that without
trust if the if the pilot didn't trust
that maintenance officer that i
wouldn't trust back if the pilot didn't
trust the flight attendant to get that
plane deplaned
right and this is where we get
micromanagers right so micromanagement
is a sign that there's a breakdown and
trust because that person
feels that they have to do everybody's
job for them right
right not necessarily because they don't
like them they might be nice people it
doesn't necessarily mean that they're
overbearing in command and control
but there's there's issues of trust
which is here let me help or
i'll just do it better myself one of one
or two of those very interesting
job as a leader is to show vulnerability
by allowing your people
to do what they're good at and lean on
them so that they get better at it so
that in those environments
you don't you don't need to step up you
can just you can just lead right that's
the
challenge as a leader so good stuff
thank you so much rich as as rich
mentioned um
we when we were putting together all of
our online courses uh when we pivoted
and coveted
um all those live courses we put up um
we looked at our book for inspiration
looked at my book for inspiration
and we we remembered that uh rich um
played such a big role in teaching me
about the the the
uh relationship between trust and
performance we said rich would you like
to
develop a course with us and teach it
and rich said what are you crazy
absolutely not we said please please
please rich please please please he said
fine fine i'll do it
um and so rich um uh has worked with us
to develop
a a class all about trust and
performance
um i think the it's on um on
simonsenic.com one it's called building
trusting teams
uh and the next one is on friday july
31st at 9 00 a.m eastern
and if you're in the book club nobody
else is listening to this
uh we have a 20 discount for you if you
want to do it the
code is book club rules all one word
book club rules
uh so you can check it out at simone dot
com slash
inspire you um rich always a pleasure
love you man take care of your family
and i'll talk to you real soon i hope
sounds good sounds good thank you
brother for having me
okay uh so good to hear from him i i've
learned so much from him um
let's jump into more questions from
everybody else shall we
um uh okay
will and resources what is this
well chapter 6 women resources okay
here's the reason i wrote will and
resources
um so we heard about trusting teams will
and resources
um you know throughout this whole book
um and we learned this the last in the
in the last chapter
about the responsibility of business you
know i had this
this responsibility of business by by um
uh milton friedman
hanging over me throughout the whole
book because this is what american and
global business is basically based on
these days
is this ridiculous responsibility of
business that's 40 years 30 years old 40
years old
um more 50 years old um
and uh and it's produced some very
uncomfortable situations in in global
business
the the decline of trust the decline of
cooperation the decline of innovation
the the the the the way we use and reuse
people
the lack of loyalty all of these things
but i recognize the importance of money
and i
and i got tired of saying in in public
forums you know people are more
important
than profit and everybody thought that i
meant profit is unimportant
um and uh and and so i had to sort of
reconcile those two and i realized that
the two currencies of business
are not just money the mistake we've
made is that we think the only currency
of business is money it's not there are
two currencies
will and resources in that order the
will of the people
and the resources available to continue
to help advance the cause you have to
have money you have to be profitable
it's like having the perfect car you
might have the perfect culture you might
have the most amazing car but if you
have no fuel
to make that car go uh
then then you never achieve anything
money is a finite resource whether
you're getting it from a customer or
from an investor
um whether you're getting it from a
stock market or uh
from other sort for uh forms of
investment
it is finite it can run out and it can
stop coming in that's why you have to
produce good
good product and good marketing to help
uh
keep the resource coming in it's like
drilling you have to keep drilling or
or putting up solar panels if you want
more energy
um you've got to have a resource
producer
um uh but will of the people is
unlimited
and and that's where good leadership
comes in and one of the things that's
been so interesting especially during
covert times
which is i think people like money money
doesn't just sit like this and it
doesn't just go like this like it's not
just a
hockey stick you know money goes like
this it can be affected by weather by
politics by
marketing you maybe have a good product
or a brad product and it goes like this
the goal is to keep the trend up right
um
or at least stable but the same thing is
with will you know people have good days
people have bad days
leaders show up badly and leaders show
up well it's like this but overall
you want to keep the trend of of the
will
um in a positive direction which is
every leader and remember leader has
nothing to do with
rank anyone can be a leader at any level
that's the important thing here this is
not just the responsibility
of senior leadership senior leadership
has to go first to model the behavior
that's ideal
but everyone who's showing up to be the
leader they wish they had
actually helps keep that will up on high
and this is why it's so important for
senior leadership to take care
of the the people in their charge who
are then
uh told to take care of the people on
their charge who then told to take
people in in
their charge it's like mom and dad
taking care of the older kids and asking
the older
kids to take care of the little kids
it's kind of like that and then what
ends up happening is you have a loving
trusting family
again good days bad days it all happens
you have ranges of emotion we are human
but that is the point of will and
resources that we have to invest in will
just like we take investment or invest
in
money um let's take some questions hello
romania hello kosovo hello malaysia
hello brazil obregado for coming
uh france this is just greece this is
amazing
i should just do the book club world
tour
um okay let's see what we have here
um always here
always loyal the dakota potato peel pie
in literary society
so good to see you uh kellyanne ritu
asked today's question
is from a statement in chapter 15 of
leaders eat last
okay it's the uh infinite game book club
but we can go retro that's okay
uh which directly correlates to the
trusting team second there's the
connection
um there's no such thing as a as virtual
trust apparently i wrote
um as we have had to pivot over the last
four and a half months are your thoughts
on virtual trust the same
as when you wrote the book or have they
shifted obviously nothing can replace
the human connection of a warm hug a
firm handshake or a high five
however have any virtual signals of
trust emerge during the prolonged
isolation
you basically asked to answer the
question what i mean by this no such
thing as virtual trust
is it's not that we cannot form trust
over a computer
what it means is um that it really is a
is a the deepest kind of trust is is
when we can interact
i mean think about it um we've had a
virtual team for years
and we built trust with our with uh with
with new team members
and we had it by the way for people who
think that we can just replace the
office and just all go virtual now
running a virtual team is way more
difficult
than running an in-person team because
you don't have high in the hallway
you don't have the just shoot in the
breeze before the meeting starts
you don't have hey want to get lunch in
a virtual
company uh everything is formalized
right you don't have
you don't have serendipity you don't
have accidental meetings in the hallway
everything is scheduled what time is the
zoom meeting what time's the conference
call what time's the zoo meeting and so
we all show up and just work there's
very little
of the of the interpersonal and
accidental stuff which is where
trust happens as isaac stern said the
famous virtuoso the famous violinist
music is what happens between the notes
well trust is what happens between the
meetings
trust is what happens between the
decisions um it's the same thing
so one of the things that we learned we
were building relationships
with people online but then when we had
our company off-site
they came together and they hugged and
they reinforced and they solidified
that relationship think about um online
relationships think about dating
can you talk to somebody online yes can
you get to know them online
yes can you start to form some sort of
relationship online yes but is it
ever really solidified until you get to
hold each other and hug each other and
say hello i've been waiting so long to
meet you
so i still believe that that there's no
such thing as virtual trust
i still think that trust is a deeply
human thing it's not something that can
exist on the computer
we can't build it every email for sure
and even when we're doing things
virtually there's tone of voice
i as you you've heard me talk about i
think phone is actually better than a
video conference very often um because i
find that people are more present
as opposed to just looking at themselves
or looking at a hole in the top of the
camera
or my favorite one is is like you're
trying very hard to make eye contact
with somebody by looking at their
eyes on your screen but what they see is
this because they're little boxes over
there anyway you get the idea
um nothing nothing beats in person so
yes i i still stand by the fact that
there's no such thing as virtual trust
um let's take another one
greetings wait was that did somebody say
greens from the north pole what was that
i missed it i lost it greetings from
cutter chile holy cow
italy oman i've been to oman
i had a lovely time there and i ate
drank camel's milk
just a little bit though because i was
told that it it upsets your stomach so i
didn't want to risk it
um okay uh nia samal even if we operate
in
an infant with an infinite mindset we
might not feel motivated
to have the will to keep going all the
time true um how do we keep ourselves
engaged with our will
intact so we can keep advancing
consistently and efficiently okay
this goes perfectly to trusting teams
none of us is smart enough
strong enough to do this thing called
life to do this thing called work to do
this thing called business alone
this is where the team comes in you
heard uh
what rich said which is the value of of
trust
on the team is not when the team is
great it's not when everything when the
conditions are great
you know people talk about their dream
teams dream teams work beautifully when
the conditions are great
but when things go sideways when things
get difficult
that's when the trust of the team really
comes to bear and so
you know it's all fine and good for us
to operate with an infinite mindset but
remember
one of the core practices of maintaining
an infinite mindset
is the is the ability and responsibility
to build relationships and take care of
others
and so if you find that your will is is
drained
and by the way i have felt it everyone
has felt it we are all dealing with the
trauma
of kovid um and for those who
you know sort of had an easier time of
it they did not compartmentalize their
their feelings they did not uh avoid
dealing with the trauma it just meant it
was going to come later
for me i've been actually dealing with
it lately it's taken me four months to
start
really feeling feeling it and the first
thing i did is i picked up the phone and
i called people and i told them how i
felt
so niha what i would recommend is pick
up the phone
and call people and tell them how you're
feeling call the people you love and say
i'm having a behind day we don't believe
in good days and bad days with our
infinite mindset they're too absolute
so if we say good day we have the false
belief that that it lasts forever and if
we say bad day we have the false belief
that it lasts forever
we have a head days and behind days this
is a journey and you're having a behind
day you
call someone and ask for help and be
there and offer your help for those
who are suffering the same uh
let's see uh let's here's a linkedin
user with no name
um where's the first place to start when
trying to change a finite company
to be an infinite player uh is trust
at leadership levels or lower
organizations or is it grassroots okay
great question so it's very common
especially in this day and age
where leadership senior leadership of a
of a company
is operating with a finite mindset um
they believe uh the will of the people
is subordinate to the money
um all they care about is performance
it's all about short-termism
um there's no just cause they're trying
to advance
and they believe growth is a cause so
this is
pervasive um and so the question is how
do you change it now the most efficient
is if senior leadership takes
responsibility and
goes through that transition it happens
um you have you've heard me talk about
bob chapman i wrote about him
extensively
in leaders eat last and i just recently
did a podcast with bob
and if you've never heard bob speak oh
my god you have to go listen
he's the way let me tell you how his
kids describe
um bob chapman they the way they
describe him is if he walks into a room
and finds a pile of [__] in the middle
of the room
bob will look up and say where's the
pony he's that kind of optimist
um uh so it can happen at the top bob
made this conversion himself he was a
finite
minded leader he became an infinite
minded leader but it doesn't have to the
tail can wag the dog and so we have to
be the leaders we wish we had we have to
start
embracing the concepts and the practices
of the infinite mindset
so we can have a cause and we can bring
it to work and say guys let me tell you
why i love
this company why i love this opportunity
and even though we have our challenges
i came to work to learn how to to be a
part of something bigger and this is the
world that i'm trying to build
and even though i may do it in this
little arena this is what i'm trying to
advance
when i come to work every day and it
could be you know create a world in
which people feel inspired safe and
fulfilled
that could be the cause that we're
trying to advance all of us to build
this inspired safe and fulfilled world
that every one of us can feel and you're
going to do it in your team
so you're going to offer them the just
cause it can be yours it can be someone
else's remember we have to find one
you're going to take responsibility for
building the trusting team for
expressing vulnerability saying how you
feel
setting the tone because if you set the
tone regardless of your rank
in the company other people will feel
safe to come to you so if you express
vulnerability
they'll close the door and say hey can i
talk to you for a second or in these day
in this day and age they'll call you and
say do you have a moment
um but you set that tone um so
so we can all be the leaders we wish we
had so if you're working in a company
that you're trying to
help them make that conversion into an
infinite mindset you lead with the
infinite mindset and what you'll find is
the people on your team will learn those
practices
and they will take them and they will
take them to other parts of the company
and at some point we will the tail wags
the dog how long i don't know
remember this is one of the reasons that
finite players don't like the infinite
mindset
it's because it's unpredictable in time
like you've heard me talking about it's
like working out
if you go to the gym every single day
for 20 minutes 100
you will get into shape 100 it is not in
doubt
when don't know and it'll be different
for everybody which means it's different
for every company
it means it's different for every team
100 it works i just don't know when
and remember finite-minded players don't
like unpredictable
they like to exert extremes amounts of
control they want the right
time the right number everything to
happen on schedule but that's not how
this works
and so we are comfortable with the
uncertainty of the time frame we're
committed to the process
that's how you convert to infinite
mindset okay let's take another question
uh got one here
from uh from deborah bearden
in nashville tennessee by the way if
you've ever had the brunch
at the omni hotel in nashville oh the
honey the biscuits
incredible um i've had the opportunity
and privilege to have a great leader for
a manager
uh she made me have even more will than
i thought that i had i love that
how do i help others lead how do i help
other leaders inspire the same
for their people so leadership is not
just about
subordination you know it's not just
about subordinates i mean
leadership is about taking care of
people so we can lead up as much as we
can lead down
through the hierarchy so for example if
if you see somebody who's in a
leadership position who may have a
position
that outranks you and they're having a
bad day
they're short-tempered they're a little
bit rough in a meeting
instead of just deciding that they're an
[__] which still might be the case by
the way
but not necessarily the case practice
what you would want them to practice
with you if you having a bad day
which is empathy so it is okay to call
somebody senior and say hey
you were a little rough on us today in
the meeting are you okay
i know it's been really tough lately i
know you're under a lot of stress i just
want to make sure you're
okay and that is
one of the ways to inspire
other leaders to help the team and again
it's a process right
they they may not they may not see the
impact of that
and then a little bit down the way
they'll start to see that you're
completely dedicated and devoted to
helping them
stay on track and and and block and
tackle and help
help lead the team where they may be
falling behind because of pressure
um and before too long they'll start
opening up to you and they'll start
learning from you and they'll start
maybe without telling you you'll start
to notice
some of their behaviors change it's like
children if you have kids
you start to change things you have a
kid who let's say has terrible tempers
and you always yell at them when they
have a temper tantrum
and you try something new you start
sitting down and say hey
what's bothering you and it doesn't
happen immediately but in time you start
to see
things change it's the exact same thing
um let's take another question
samantha gonzalez i'm having issues with
my general manager
who is completely new to my company he
constantly
has his foot in his mouth syndrome he
has constantly his foot and mouth
syndrome
he doesn't inspire me at all uh and i'm
uh and
i'm the one who's constantly pulling the
rope in front
um well when someone's new
there's all kinds of insecurities that
come with that and very often
new people especially new people with
positions of authority feel the need
to prove that they are worthy of being
hired
they feel they want to make sure that
leadership knows that they deserve the
position
um and sometimes they want to sort of
let everybody know that
that that they're here it's very often
insecurity
uh chanel the company chanel um
they do something that i love which is
all senior leaders
when they're newly hired are not allowed
to speak in meetings for 90 days
think about that for a second they're
basically saying we know you're smart
we hired you we trust ourselves we know
you're good
now shut up and learn and i just
absolutely love that i love the idea
it's easier to do in a big company than
a small company but i love the idea
that new people are not a lot new
leaders are not allowed to speak in
meetings
they're there to learn so one of the
things you can do
is again have empathy we don't know uh
the reason it could be that your gm
um you know hasn't studied leadership
and is only doing uh uh
what he thinks what he thinks works or
what he's seen other people do maybe
he's never had a good
role model um so just go to him and say
hey
welcome to the company when i remember
and talk about yourself i find that the
easiest way to have difficult
conversations with people
is when you can relate things to
yourself because they can't argue your
experiences and your feelings
so you can say hey i remember when i
first joined the company
i was like a duck out of water i was
flailing and i didn't know what to do
and i found myself sort of um
sort of speaking too much sometimes and
all i know
is i was so grateful when somebody came
to me and said hey don't worry i got
your back
so hey boss i don't know what you're
going through and maybe this is totally
irrelevant in which case it doesn't
matter
but i just want you to know you're new
to the company i'm here to help you
navigate i'm here to help explain
anything
and please if you ever want to lean on
me i'm i'm happy to help
teach you about or share with you about
our culture and how things get here so
that you can be super successful and
happy and get the same joy
out of this place that i do give that a
try okay
um yes
smoothie jorge dear simon
what are the foundation of the infinite
mindset for instance
how shall i start my day knowing that i
have only 24 hours
oh i love that one jorge asks um what
are the
foundations of an imminent mindset how
do i maintain an image and mindset
knowing that today i only have 24 hours
in the day
it's a finite day remember the infinite
game
is not the absence of finite games the
infinite game is the context
within which those finite games exist
there are always finite games in the
infinite game so for example
uh in an airline a gate agent who has to
get a plane to leave on time
there's a beginning middle and end we
absolutely want them to maintain a
finite mindset
because we want that plane to leave on
time we get really frustrated
when they when when it doesn't go that
way and when that finite
thing is over they're going to do it
again and they're going to do it again
it's filled with
finite experiences throughout the day
however we want that gate agent to be
aware of the infinite context in other
words we want them to treat passengers
well
we want them to speak nicely to them to
be polite and sometimes maybe even
having a short delay
to do the right thing let someone who's
running late on the plane
because we want those people to come
back and do business with us again
and that's more of the infinite mind in
this which is we have to stay in the
game we have to keep this going beyond
this one thing
and this is where bureaucrats are so
frustrating they seem to lack any
context of the infinite game
and they want to talk about this right
now and that's why they're so obsessed
with what the rules say
because there's no context and so for
you to maintain an infinite mindset it's
to understand that every day you
have is contributing to something even
bigger
now there was something i read about a
bunch of years ago which i absolutely
love the idea of if you want to try this
jorge
um we know what the average lifespan of
of
of a person who lives where you live is
right you can just look it up on
online right find out the average
lifespan of a of a male
in in wherever you live it'll be in the
mid 70s right
so that means you can do the math and
you can figure out
how many years until you hit that age
you can figure out how many weeks you
have
until you hit that average age right and
what i want you to do is go buy two fish
bowls
and i want you to buy a bunch of marbles
and you're going to put
a specific number of marbles in one fish
bowl it's the number of weeks
you have left on the planet earth that's
what's going to go in fishbowl number
one
and every sunday night you're gonna pick
up a marble
and say was this a week worth living did
i contribute to something bigger than
myself
did i in some way shape or form grow
myself or help someone grow and if the
answer is yes
you can put that marble in the other
bowl if the answer is no you throw that
marble away that was a wasted week i
mean you could you could do it daily if
you really wanted to that's a lot of
marbles
and then you reach that average age and
now you're living on borrowed time
and the point is is we want to try and
make sure that every week that we live
is contributing to something bigger than
ourselves that it's just more
than achieving the finite goals and that
we want to live
with the second bowl of marbles
completely full that mean we lived a
life worth living and we lived a life
that contributed so all of your 24-hour
days contributed to something even
bigger
and grander and to the lives of others
because truly it is service that gives
our lives meaning
it is not simply accomplishment or
uh our resumes nobody nobody wants their
resume published in their
in their obituary you know we we talk
about what how
how people were to others that's how we
want to be talked about
uh okay let's take a look at uh hello
sherry and simon
uh from the cool cats club in northern
california
uh for a leader to effectively
prioritize the will of the people
do they need to thoroughly understand
the company's resource depth and
limitations
in order to convince others of this
preference
um that is a great question um
it is important let me think let me
dissect that one for a little bit
uh for a leader to effectively
prioritize the will of the people do
they need to thoroughly understand the
company's resource depth and limitations
in order to convince others of this
preference okay
so a good leader one of the hard things
about leadership
is is that there's the constant
balancing of the will and the resources
and understanding that decisions that
prioritize one can sacrifice the other
and the hardest hardest thing about
leadership and i'm learning this
firsthand in cobit
the hardest hardest thing about
leadership is is being able to balance
those things not just in the immediacy
of the
of the now but to be able to balance
those things and understand what the
repercussions and secondary effects are
going to be
after a month after three months after
six months after a year
um and um and understanding
that um sometimes on purpose and
sometimes by accident
which we take a hit to the resources
um uh because we're trying to do the
right thing
and sometimes we have to do the right
thing
and it takes a hit to the will and it's
in it's this constant battle
and the effective leaders um
are the effective leaders will will will
feel
will feel that battle the ineffective
leaders this is not a discussion this is
not a battle
it's only resources the ineffective
leaders there's no
conflict and there's no battle it's only
will and by the way that organization
won't survive very long
uh the resource organization will
survive longer but it won't last forever
and it'll have a short unhappy life
um and so the the if there is stress
in managing those two then then i think
that leader is is
is aware of the of the importance of
will and how to
manage it and and and keep it strong for
a long time
but understanding that those things are
it's an ocean so uh yeah
it's hard i guess is the answer um
do you have one over there do you have
one we have a um uh
here's one from uh magnus florian from
facebook
florin sorry magnus uh uh what do you
think is the number one trait
that need that is needed to meet a
sustainable
future or if we maintain an infinite
mindset i think the number one trait
um is courage i think um it takes
huge amounts of courage to do the right
things for the long term it's easier to
do the right things for the short term
it's easier to do the
things that are right that make you look
good to wall street or your boss or
something like that
those are those are the easy decisions
because you're actually not considering
what the right thing to do is you're
considering what will make me look good
what will help me get the promotion what
will help me get the bonus what will
help wall street reward me
um to make the courageous decision
sometimes means being unpopular
in the short term um and that's hard
so i think courage is king um you know
i've had this discussion with friends of
mine as well
who who rank integrity higher and i
still think it takes courage
to be in integrity i i think when when
confronted with very difficult decisions
um that to make the decision that that
is that is the one that that
reeks of integrity i think continues to
require courage
remember the pressures on us are
overwhelming um whether it's pressure
from our boss
pressure from wall street pressure from
the market you know pressure of keeping
a business going the pressures are
overwhelming
and to continue to march down um
a path of integrity is uh
it's courage and as we've talked about
before um
courage i don't believe is some deep
internal fortitude i believe courage
comes from trust
and that when we have trusting
relationships we have more courage when
somebody says i got your back i believe
in you
you got this no matter what happens i'll
be there with you it gives us the
courage to do the right thing
maintain your strong relationships take
care of others that's how you build
courage
we'll do one more
hello lucas um why then with all this
knowledge
present then most companies still hire
promote clearly
people with a finite mindset
lucas asks the 10 million dollar
question lucas asked with all of this
knowledge present
why do companies still hire finite
minded players
who are just performance driven is that
basically what he asked
because it's easier because an infinite
mindset is hard work
why do people get um why do people take
uh
why do healthy people take uh diet pills
instead of exercising and eating well
because it's easier um you know we're
all we're all subj
i mean look at look at most of the
things that we do in life look at most
of the industries that thrive
most of the industries thrive on our
laziness
right i mean what's amazon
it's shopping for lazy people you don't
have to go to the store
pick things up i mean you know i'm
speaking
historically we don't go to stores at
all anymore um
uh i mean so many services that we buy
are to make our lives easier and by the
way i believe in that that's good when
something makes our life easier
or helps make life better and we
perceive value in whatever that thing is
we're willing to pay money for that
service
um that's that's where value is derived
um we continue to hire uh performance
people i think for a few reasons one
it's easier
and two because maybe we're working in a
culture that rewards
us personally for somebody else's
short-term success
um you know if you're working on a team
that's all about short-term short-term
short-term you're going to hire people
who are really good at short-term
um i really think it's funny when wall
street for example
says we have to pay ridiculous
exorbitant salaries that are completely
out of whack with normal
um uh compensation uh disparities
because we need to pay the high prices
to attract the best talent
uh no what you're doing is attracting
people who
just like to make a ton of money um you
could also say we're
trying to change the world we're trying
to do something powerful we're trying to
create a world in which is
inspired safe and fulfilled and if we're
successful at that everybody will thrive
and do well and share in the spoils but
we're looking for people who want to do
that guess who you'll attract
the the best companies in the world
don't necessarily pay the highest
salaries
they pay fair salaries they pay
competitive salaries
but they don't necessarily pay the best
salaries because they're offering more
than just money
and you derive more than just pay by
working at these companies
the companies where it's all about money
then they're only hiring performance
people because that's
their whole business model
but this isn't that why we're having
this book club because
we consider this a movement this is not
a book for us
this is not just a fun discussion to
have on social media to help pass the
time
in our day we show up here because for
us this is a movement
that every single one of us here who who
is a part of this wants to see change in
the world and wants to be a part of that
change
that we want to be the leaders we wish
we had we maintain our infinite mindset
because we want to be the tail that wags
the dog at a macro
level we want to be the one that changes
our nation that changes our economy
and and 20 years from now 30 years from
now who knows how long it will take took
us
30 40 years to get to where we are now
that 20 30 40 years from now
that the business landscape will
completely completely different that
loyalty be
loyalty will be something that is ex
that is that is commonplace
that trust is something that flows up
and down companies normally
that the the dysfunctional companies the
hype the the performance focus companies
become the minority and not the other
way around like it is now
that's why we do this and that's why
book club is so important remember book
club is not about reading a book
book club is about creating the book
club so that we read a book together
it's about relationships
we are practicing the principles we're
reading about together
in the mere way in which we're showing
up today
this is why i love doing this
because we're a part of something bigger
than ourselves and that goes back to the
question that was asked before i think
was jorge's question
uh i only have 24 hours in the day so
what have we done today to advance the
greater good what have we done
done today to create a world in which
the vast majority of people will wake up
inspired feel safe wherever they are and
return home fulfilled at the end of the
day end the day fulfilled by the work
that they do
we're learning skills we're studying
we're practicing sometimes
we're in study mode sometimes we're in
execution mode that's why we're here
today
to be a part of something bigger than
ourselves thank you everyone so much for
coming
i absolutely love book club it's one of
my favorite things i do all week
um we're going to be back next friday
july 31st 1pm
eastern uh for continued conversation of
the infinite game oh i had a pink tab in
here i wonder what it was
i don't remember i was gonna share a
story but i forgot um
next week we're gonna be doing uh
chapters eight and nine
ethical fading and worthy rival ethical
fading it is fascinating we'll have
deep conversation about ethical fading
bring your questions about ethical
fading and worthy rival
two really really fun chapters i'm
looking forward to those we will be live
on youtube facebook linkedin and i guess
twitter
and twitter so you can show up in any of
those platforms to ask live questions
plus if you want to submit questions in
advance that come up
in your book club discussions that's why
we did it um
please send them to book club at
simonsenic.com again that's
book club at simonsenic.com to
pre-submit your questions that your book
club has
send us pictures of your book club we'd
love to see them uh
you know send us the picture of the zoom
or whatever of you guys reading your
book together
if you don't live near each other
if you want to watch uh re-watch any of
what you
heard today or share it with a friend
who may have missed the session the
recordings will be
up and available uh permanently
uh on youtube facebook and linkedin and
again
if you want to go try rich divini's
class on building trusting teams
smart dude uh uh
please take advantage of the 20 discount
for the month of july
uh it's book club rules 20 off take
advantage
thank you for joining this has made my
day and it's just
still the morning i'm already on cloud
nine
uh i'm on cloud 10. um
uh take care of yourself take care of
each other
i'll see you next week